من القدس مراسله فرانس 24 ليلى عوده ولكن
قبل ان اسالك ليلى نشير الى ان قناه فرانس
فانت كات ومجموعه فرانس ميدياموند تدين
الاعتدال لفظي والجسدي الذي تعرضت اليه
مراسلتنا وايضا المصور الذي معها خلال
تغطيه التغطيه للانفجار الذي حصل في القدس
وانتم تشاهدون على الشاشه ما الذي حصل مع
مراسلتنا ليلى عوده
السلام عليكم
هل اعلنت جهه معينه عن مسؤوليتها في ما
حصل في العمليتين
عن اي من العمليتين في القدس سواء عند
محطه الحافلات في الجزء العربي الغربي او
حتى في حيه ريموت القريب عن
محطه الحافلات ولكن بطبيعه الحال الصحافه
الاسرائيليه وفقا لتحليلاتها وايضا وفقنا
لمصادر امنيه تداولت عده وجهات من بينها
لم يكن هناك استبعاد ان يكون ضلوع لحركه
حماس في مثل هذه العمليه وهناك البعض قال
بان قد تكون هناك علاقه لحركه فتح التي
كان لها بصمات فيما وصفت بحسب العلامه
الاسرائيلي بطبيعه واليه هذه همم
التفجيرات ووضع العبوات والتفعيل تفجيرها
عن بعض ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه كما قلت ما من
جهر رسم يتمنى هذه الاغنيه التي ادت الى
مقتل الاسرائيلي شكرا لك ليلى عوده من
القدس